alors monsieur guilbeault bonjour
bonjour si votre première semaine en pas
que ministre c'est terminé nous enviera
demain c'est à l'accueil 26 comme ça se
passe
deux choses je pense que du côté des
négociations ça va plutôt bien il ya
un optimisme prudent lorsqu'on parle aux
gens il reste encore une semaine il
reste beaucoup de travail à faire et
encore plusieurs enjeux sur les sur
lesquels les pays ne s'entendent pas et
je suis ça avec la délégation canadienne
de très près
d'autre part je pense que les vides à
mal le fait que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et telle en début de
semaine
c'est plutôt rare d'instruction à la fin
et c'est une idée intéressante puisque
on a vu que plusieurs leaders ont
convenu avec glasgow avec de nouveaux
engagements que ce soit sur la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
nouvelles mesures pour aller plus loin
plus vite et du côté de l'adaptation du
si qui est un enjeu très important pour
pour les pays en voie de développement
je pense qu' il faut saluer la
présidence britannique qui
a faim de choses qu'on n'avait jamais
réussi à faire jusqu'à maintenant
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on parle à la
fois de changement climatique et de
protection de la biodiversité est
historiquement nous toujours parler de
ces choses-là en parallèle dans deux
conventions différentes conférences pour
la biodiversité exactement mais
l'atmosphère et la biosphère ça
fonctionne pas comme ça
et là on voit que c'est très intégrée et
il faut il faut que ce soit comme ça et
je pense que ne serait-ce que ça
ce serait une succession si on repartait
de glasgow juste avec sage et il a aidé
accord sur le 100 milliards ce serait
déjà très bien je pense qu'on peut faire
mieux quand même je pense aussi que la
communauté internationale
elle le voit depuis plusieurs années
mais c'est encore plus frappant à quel
point le canada est redevenu
un acteur de premier plan et mais
on le sent on l'entend dans les
corridors les gens sont très heureux que
le canadien joue ce rôle proactif que
nous avions déjà joué une certaine
époque mais ça s'était effritée avec le
temps il a clairement
les gens par le canada reste quand même
le plus grand pollueur par capita on n'a
pas réussi depuis 2015 à réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
certifie que 10 avec les cibles
actuelles on n'arrivera pas vers où on
veut s'en aller est ce que le canada ne
devrait pas annoncer de nouvelles cibles
une question qui est qui qui très
importante nous sommes un grand
producteur un pays producteur de pétrole
et de gaz un grand premier plan alors eu
le défi est de taille au canada et c'est
vrai que nous n'avons pas encore réussi
à réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre
de façon absolue mais lorsqu'on regarde
vers où la courbe se diriger sur
l'horizon 2030 lorsqu'on a pris le
pouvoir en 2013 et où nous sommes
présentement donc on a ramené cette
courbe pour reprendre l'expression
consacrée de monsieur avoue dorn aplati
cette courbe la
niveau au même niveau que 2005 alors que
lorsqu'on a lorsqu'on prend le pouvoir
cette courbe là elles étaient 12 à 14%
au-dessus donc le travail que nous avons
commencé à faire au canada fonctionne
mais il faut il faut aller plus vite il
faut en faire plus c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi le premier ministre annoncer de
nouvelles mesures ici lors la conférence
de glasgow soi que nous allions mettre
en place un plafond sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre du secteur du
pétrole et du gaz nous sommes le seul
produit grand producteur de draw carbure
au monde avoir pris cet engagement
nous allons éliminer les subventions aux
combustibles fossiles deux ans plus tôt
que nos partenaires du g20
et nous avons annoncé plusieurs
plusieurs autres mesures notamment que
le canada et d'autres pays comme les
etats unis la grande bretagne nous nous
sommes engagés à cesser le financement
de développement
le projet d'hydrocarbures dans les pays
en voie de développement par plusieurs
de nos institutions par exemple comme
l'exportation de développement du canada
alors
donc nous prenons des posons des gestes
additionnel pour pour dans le cas de la
lutte aux changements climatiques à
l'intérieur du canada et à l'extérieur
aussi
et c'est vrai que on y est on y est pas
encore tout à fait mais avant la
conférence de paris le monde se diriger
vers un réchauffement de leurs 23.5
degrés celsius avant la conférence de
glasgow le monde se diriger vers un
réchauffement de 2 points 6 degrés
celsius et là nous avons appris cette
semaine par la voix du secrétaire
général de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie que suite à suite aux
engagements que les pays ont pris juste
avant ou pendant la conférence de
glasgow la planète se dirige vers un
réchauffement d'un point 8 degrés
celsius évidemment tout ceci les pays
font ceux qui ce qu'il dit qu'ils
allaient faire mais donc je reviens à ma
question est ce qu'on devrait pas
annoncer des cibles plus ambitieuses on
doit donner l'exemple si on demande aux
pays en développement qui sont qui ont
déjà un fardeau énorme sur les épaules
qui doivent en faire davantage pour y
arriver devrions-nous pas me montrer
l'exemple et avoir des cibles plus
ambitieuses des cibles qui répondent aux
exigences finalement pour y arriver à
maintenir
5,8 s'est passé bien n'est ce pas
l'accord de paris dit
de garder le réchauffement sous la barre
du degré celsius et le plus près
possible du 1.5 donc à 1.8 on est quand
même pas mal dans la marge de ce que les
pays s'étaient entendus à paris mais
c'est exactement ce que vous proposez
c'est exactement ce que nous avons fait
c'est à dire que lorsque nous arrivons
au pouvoir en 2015 les objectifs du
canada sont de 30 % sous le niveau de
2005 d'ici 2030 on appréhende représente
un premier plan d'action de lutte aux
changements climatiques on en a présenté
une version bonifiée à la fin de 2020
nous avons l'un des prix sur la
pollution les plus élevés au monde alors
que
nous avons commencé à travailler là
dessus au canada il n'y a que 5 1
comparativement des pays comme la des
états comme le québec la californie
l'union européenne qui a commencé
pratiquement au début des années 2000
donc nous sommes en mode rattrapage au
canada mais nous avons moi je pense
qu'il faut faire attention aux débats
sur sur les cibles on a eu beaucoup de
débats sur les cibles au canada au cours
des 25 dernières années et le résultat
est plus les résultats sont pas très
concluant en moi plutôt que de mettre
une cible sans savoir comment va
l'atteindre jamais qu'on travaille à
développer un plan d'action à mettre des
mesures en place et là c'est exactement
ce qu on a fait quand on voit que ça
fonctionne on peut dire que l'on va
prendre une cible plus ambitieuse et la
conversation l'une des conversations qui
va commencer sa glace gauche c'est
justement là dessus comment est ce que
les pays puis essentiellement les plus
grands pollueurs
on parle essentiel beaucoup des pays du
g20
quelle va être la prochaine étape alors
les négociations vont commencer pour que
fort probablement d'ici 2025 les pays
comme le canada les états unis la grande
bretagne la france le japon s'engage à
prendre des engagements plus ambitieux
en matière de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et en matière des
deux pays en voie de développement alors
c'est exactement ce que nous faisons je
sais trop où était ce la semaine
dernière il a fait quelques annonces
il a clairement dit que le canada allait
faire mieux puis il s'engage à faire
beaucoup de choses maintenant ça ce sont
des premières j'ai fait tous des
promesses électorales pendant la
campagne est ce qu'il ya un plan
climatique qui va être plus précis qui
va donner le la marche à suivre pour se
rendre concret qu'on devrait voir
bientôt mais en fait vous êtes ce sont
des promesses il ya des engagements très
clairs nous avons d'oubli l'aide est ce
qu'on appelle la finance climatique donc
avant la conférence de glasgow c'était
de 2.3 milliards nous sommes à 5.3
milliards maintenant alors ça c'est un
c'est pas une promesse c'est un
engagement ferme c'est très concret de
ca 1 milliard sera dédiée à aider les
pays en voie de développement à réduire
leur dépendance au charbon qui est
la cible numéro un à l'échelle
planétaire en matière de lutte aux
changements climatiques
on a également annoncé qu'un autre
milliards iraient à trouver à financer
des projets qui sont justement
au nexus de la protection de la
biodiversité et de la lutte aux
changements climatiques nous avons l'un
des plans les plus concrets les plus
étoffées sur la planète celui de 2020
maintenant effectivement nous avons pris
de nouveaux engagements lors il va
falloir bonifier ce plan là et c'est ce
à quoi je vais m'attaquer avec mes
collègues bien sûr du cabinet au cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois il ya des spécialistes qui disent
que 2050 pour la carboneutralité c'est
trop tard aspect canada pourrait pas
essayer de l'atteindre plus rapidement
il ya effectivement des chercheurs de la
firme moi je pense qu'il faut essayer de
l'atteindre le plus rapidement possible
le consensus présentement c'est qu'il
faut il faut le faire pour 2050 mais si
on voit que nous sommes capables d'y
arriver plus rapidement alors on le
frôle le plus tôt c'est mieux parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre que plus on
attend plus les impacts des changements
climatiques vont être importants plus la
biosphère va mettre du temps à retrouver
un équilibre que nous avons bouleversé
alors si c'est possible de le faire plus
rapidement faut absolument faire le
transport au canada c'est un problème
important les véhicules jeudi c'est une
journée dédiée au transport
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que le canada peut
faire on peut proposer pour qu'on réduit
ça c'est une partie importante en fait
des émissions de gaz à effet c'est le
cas de nos émissions avec le secteur
énergétique c'est la plus grande source
d'émission au canada nous procédons
présentement des investissements
historiques en matière de transport
collectif nous n'avons jamais vu le
niveau d'investissement qui lui a
présentement de la part du gouvernement
fédéral
partout au pays en transport collectif
donc présentement 300 projets de
transports collectifs qui sont en
construction partout au pays il ya des
gens qui ont besoin de voiture notre
approche est bien travaillons à ce que
ces voitures là soit d'une part les plus
efficaces possibles lorsqu'elles
utilisent de l'essence et et pourquoi
pas prendre un virage de plus en plus
important vers l'électrification des
transports alors c'est pourquoi mes
l'électrification des transports savait
pas dire moi véhicules sur les routes on
l'a bien vu dans d'autres pays voiture
électrique c'est une partie de la
solution mais ça fait quand même plus de
voitures sur les routes c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi nous investissons à peu près
trente cinq fois plus dans les
transports collectifs que dans
l'électrification je suis d'accord avec
vous
simplement penser qu'on va s'attaquer au
problème du transport en remplaçant une
voiture à essence par des voitures
électriques moi je pense qu'on passe à
côté de quelque chose semaines numéro 2
s'est hissée assez crucial cette semaine
qui commence l'article numéro 6 est très
important pour la réussite de ce sommet
article numéro deux donc c'est pour ce
marché international du carbone êtes
vous confiant qu'on va trouver un accord
collectif
c'est un article important mais
et je pense que beaucoup beaucoup de
gens souhaiteraient qu'on arrive à un
accord sur sur l'article 6 et surf sur
la mise en place d'un marché
international du carbone du carbone
remarquez que déjà dans le cadre de
l'accord de paris en vertu de l'article
6.2 il ya les balbutiements d'un marché
du carbone qui qui
qui commence à être mis en place
mais si on arrive à adopter l'ensemble
des règles autour de l'article de
l'article 6 ça pourrait permettre un
marché du carbone plus élaborées de de
se développer c'est un enjeu important
c'est certainement l'une des choses dont
les pays par le plus je soupçonne qu'on
va réussir qu'on va probablement réussir
à s'entendre sur certains éléments par
rapport à l'article 6 mais peut-être pas
tout et c'est pas la fin du monde
glasgow n'est pas là la dernière chance
pour pour la mise en oeuvre des éléments
de l'accord de paris alors je suis
je suis d'un optimisme prudent